uno de los atletas más importantes de
todos los tiempos en el año 58 ganó su
primer mundial con 17 años e iniciaba el
mito Pelé Pero antes en Brasil le
pusieron otros apodos gasolina por el
color del petróleo también alemán como
una forma de ridiculizarle con el color
blanco de los europeos e incluso criollo
llegando a ser Comparado con un animal
fue su éxito el que le ayudó a derribar
muros convirtiéndose en una de las
primeras leyendas negras del deporte
lo que hizo Pelé fue Elevar la
autoestima de los negros brasileños la
autoestima de los jugadores negros pero
también la autoestima de toda una
población no solo de Brasil sino del
mundo
puso en el mundo a Brasil el país con la
mayor población negra fuera de África y
el último país occidental en abolir la
esclavitud en 1888 y pese a los agravios
pelea acostumbró a la negación
confesando que siempre prefirió ignorar
los insultos racistas de las gradas una
falta de compromiso político que muchos
le achacaron toda su vida y en mis
investigaciones en ningún momento de su
trayectoria fue un revolucionario
siempre fue un ídolo del fútbol siempre
fue un tipo comprometido consigo mismo
con su talento y su carrera siempre fue
Pelé
similar sucedió con su relación cercana
con la dictadura militar otro de los
grandes mitos del fútbol brasileño
Romario llegó a decir incluso que
callado Pelé es un poeta reconvirtiendo
la frase con la que se les solía
relacionar aquella de que Pelé convirtió
el fútbol en poesía